said Oh God come alone smashing oh my
god the meatball is glorious
very fun hey you bracelet have you seen
Fred please spend some dokoni this guy
oh god oh god what the hell you can't
prop aah
stay away from me where did you take
sweat I delete you I haven't played in
so long I don't remember spent time with
that oh damn it
who are you oh god I this is my pool
stop it
you were supposed to look after him it's
okay you're still good dog even though I
don't remember the name get down from
there I'll shoot if you don't say well
sweat oh sorry I shoot anyway yeah help
me
you're again the third dirty spent so
long of sake brewery days okay let's go
let's find him this way we can find him
quicker let's go you're against murder
get oh my god
IKEA Tower the first so glorious in the
sky man I did so much in this game I
haven't played in over a month dude this
is crazy
that's crazy alright it's mine crazy
I'll murder each and every one of these
chickens until I find spent tell me
where spend this tell me worse - tell me
worse when this tell me worse when this
tell me worse when this all right you
live who maybe he was on top of IKEA
stay here you're against Mergen IKEA
meatball ten maybe yes at the boat i fly
to boat sweat oh here's something
it's all a pretty elaborate asmita
fleeta let's we'd have it damn it Oliver
it has made of you have you seen him
where is he
look
okay you cool oh my god virgin toad all
right we'll find him together
maybe you seen at his house good call
you're smarter than you look
elaborate as meetha pittha maybe he's in
barrel this is so ridiculous how do I
lose a dog
I'm the worst owner in the planet don't
judge me
your turtle turtles don't have feelings
everyone knows this now go back in boat
and enjoy the boat come here enjoy the
boat
I told I tell you this there you go all
right Turtles
have you seen maybe I can fish up my dog
that makes sense right so there's a
bunch of new stuff in the game now I
don't have such a boomer now all the
Millennials have taken over this game I
don't know how to play anymore
shut up what lab what the hell are you
doing we are on a quest to find dog and
you're just chilling god damn you're
sexy though are you want some fish all
right fine I guess it's been a while
here I got you some fish oh my god you
stop purring you're making me
uncomfortable that you're making virgin
toad oh my god are you two a thing now
is that what happened all right here we
go
caught you a rock on if you'll be quiet
I'd give it to you just slap him with it
Jesus Christ ah I'm outies maybe at ship
he is how do I ever activate this I
forgot Sheen DS run by themselves I'm
confused I thought these like Ryan by
themself
Oh God
wow that was amazing Wow
I can't believe I built that bajo oh
yeah I had the roller coaster remember
that does it still work
oh my god yeah alright maybe we can spot
scent from here oh my god Duke she's
gonna die okay she didn't die
lucky you elaborate that you didn't die
oh look at this part I forgot about this
so cool all right doesn't MIT okay works
come on that's cool that's cool you know
this is cool oh yeah it loops I forgot
about that dude I'm gonna freakin
engineer dude this is science what do
you want world peace
not gonna happen elaborate that not with
people like you in the world just help
me find uragan Smith I forgot a top hat
hey let me Dad what's his name I forgot
about my god he's real man he's real man
I think we should bet I think we should
bail maybe maybe he's over here in the
cow titties place hey guys have you seen
him doc Oh doc Oh doc oh-ho all right
all right all right
[Music]
again I hate her I've always disliked
olla whoa you can activate it so easy
now look at that
they must have patched a range maybe
this is still work oh my god the range
is open now we'll have it there oh my
god oh my god my slaves
wake up no more stinky blinky all the
bosses away so we can just harm our way
yeah that's right library that do you
tell them you tell them tell them
yes that's right you heard from the new
manager that's right elaborate that will
stay here to me are you stuck or
something she will stay here to make
sure that you do y'all but you do y'all
otherwise you go back in Frick shame
bear over thought oh oh I'll have to
deal with that lady try to escape the
Freak chamber you freak ah yeah I keep
forgetting what I built
this is what happens when you try can I
activate this oh I can no oh this is so
sad he dead
wow I am devastated by the fact that he
died it really hurts me so much that you
could be next
oh wait I have oh my god I put it on
each and every single one of them and
you don't want to be next ah this is me
rediscovering what I built this is
what's good about having no memory oh my
god you're in there too alright you have
to go you have to go oh my god you made
me kill bling ball my favorite strict
chamber pick it you can't oh my god not
bit PPP oh god what a disaster alright
I'll send one more up yeah it's [ __ ]
sake oh I removed their eye removed
their railway for some reason I don't
remember why all right you just stay
there then just say I elaborate that I'm
trusting you to look after them
Hey look after them while I look for
trend okay we're cool that's cool
shut up shut your freaking mouth all
right or else I will not feed you
anymore vicious alright you better do it
alright cool
okay alright that takes care of that by
which yes maybe I left them in
Netherlands that's right that's what
it's called
I remember now damnit I thought you were
Spain
I don't even know your name useless Rudy
that alright
have you seen Sven you have it that I
have to have to solve a riddle to find
sin oh my god tell me in the bing-bong
there's a pling plong but what is plain
blow what happened here
hey it's too dangerous don't follow me
what's that you love Sven - and you want
to help me fine
I don't know never mind all right dad
hey go back
it's not safe we keep the cats in
another land Fred oh god I miss him too
I miss him so much
god damn where is he so I think they're
making another update I don't know if
it's out yet I have some gold actually I
think they like reactor gold now hey hey
I got gold hey look I'm a rapper look I
got I got items come on come on me oh
god what if he left me for real what if
I took so long and you just decided to
leave you know what I mean I mean that's
entirely possible
all right I'm gonna rename you because I
don't know your name and it's getting
your spend spend the cat okay cool
cuz you look like it well he follow me
through the portal spend the cat come on
follow me yes
all right we may have lost send but we
have gained spend the cat I think this
is win all right all right come on oh my
god elaborate that stop it but I don't
want you come back come back come back
there we go stop stop stop stop that
stop it now stop it now
this is so dumb come back here everyone
has to be safe no more I don't I
literally could not care less bye
YouTube all right you mean nothing to me
nothing we're still a bit that oh my god
Oh everything was supposed to look after
the ranch boys how you playing Minecraft
because I don't think this is how you
used to play Minecraft hey get back here
you disgust me stop setting on the chest
you clearly don't deserve to sit on
chest no god dammit I'm stuck here now
with you guys aren't I
ah god I fell in my I fell in my home
[Music]
[Laughter]
can you get down from there why are you
sitting on a chest yes yes stop there we
go now watch well every tie will kill
any one of you if you don't pay
attention okay you do after you cool so
everyone is here and we're friends do
you stay there alright we're friends oh
my god yard again no ok ok ok you are I
have to name yet aside I he doesn't have
a name I'll name you d E
[Music]
because no where the hell did he go
hey you are okay hey go deep go be a
good dog DP do okay uragan you need to
stop I need it's dangerous to walk alone
yeah
oh my god I almost died there we go why
are you so black what happened to you
stop it not that there's anything wrong
seriously what's wrong with you stop it
deep there into deep man oh we haven't
looked in the church maybe it's in the
Council of water shape Oh council water
shape please I need guidance I
sacrificed my eggs all of my eggs are
yours please my god they must be so
angry I haven't given my daily Sacre
agreeable sacrifice in years it wasn't
my fault I have to take break from you
to please God what is this do what is
this
why am I here Who am I
have you say it's bad no okay what was
this again I swear this was something do
I place it here
oh no no
shut up damn it
maybe oh of course he's at IKEA
of course home nah I don't have any
gunpowder I literally can't get up there
oh no say hey I must have gunpowder
somewhere please Quan why'd I have
everything so organized with nothing in
it I guess I can just build myself up
there actually first let's check a Kia
tower to worry of course I had the cake
ladder cake ladder it reaches to the
sky's cake leather peepee poo-poo buys
this is good actually
all right here we go yard again one
Jurgen - Jurgen - and you're gonna one
what they're sheep where we see guide me
I have no choice but to build alright
here we go
I do it for my dog my diamond dog
damn it's cool to see what you built
from a high perspective
Sven I'm coming I'm so close I think I
can smell him
jean-paul Gaultier his favorite perfume
he get all the [ __ ] with it oh yeah I
remember
I built out the city so it would
repopulate and I made the shelter around
it this is the last thing I did this was
the last thing I did cool I'm glad it
works so good I'm glad you guys are safe
in there that's it
goddamn it is there because I have this
here yeah it is
i overestimated how dumb these people
are underestimated all right please come
in
those'll come up thank you oh my god I
forgot how getting annoying this kitty
I'm trying to protect you from yourself
and your stupidity thank you
never again is it covered everywhere of
course this is the last place I was how
could I forget Spain oh my god I'm so
sorry
a doll I'm back I'm back I love you
please please I give more food you can
eat forever you can eat forever snouts
man oh my god
oh that minecraft series can continue
that strength since you are here yes you
have to die comes Jesus Christ went be
careful careful Smurf all way I built
this so that you could like ride through
it that that was the idea of it right
you step here or something yeah so no
[Music]
he's crazy
come on Sven you have to say hi to
friend sees sense they hide to all the
new chicken friends I like to kill them
[Music]
what's that I shouldn't kill oh okay I
guess I won't do it
sorry chicken I I guess I misjudged you
I thought they wanted to kill Wow Oh
meet your new friend your name was Seth
deep not interested I'm sorry they maybe
maybe in the future I don't care
I don't think he cares somebody deep no
one really came here super oh oh okay
alright okay I know he doesn't have Sean
Paul guilty here but at least be French
alright you to be friends now
hey oh they love each other they made a
baby damn deep I didn't think you had it
in you oh my god there's baby now you're
so cute
look at his tiny little legs and his
giant head your humongous oh my god
glorious day today is glorious day your
chat named him named him for me I don't
know what to name it deep can you chill
I need you to chill I cannot I cannot
all right you're gonna luckily I have
more birch swim cat look after spend
chal
right spend you haven't met too
elaborate estimate i in so long actually
going in here let me tell you looking at
you're supposed to look after them Mike
what you're hungry I have some chicken
there you go Castle of chicken spent so
n do not something do not talk to them
do not you cannot be working so then you
cannot replace oh my
oh my god what's that what did you tell
him oh my god what does he do it can you
[Laughter]
alright let's go let's go
keep working hard elaborate uh keep
working hard I appreciate it so much the
ranch yes oh you're again there's
someone I want you to meet your best
friend in the entire universe that's so
cute
that's so sweet they love each other
I think I have achieved my goal here we
found spent an entire episode but it was
worth they wasn't it's vain there's baby
now named the child for me please
there's peace in the world there's peace
there's world peace in Berlin since I
don't know what the new updates are can
you guys please fill me in and let me
know what you want me to do in Minecraft
it has been so long
give me suggestions and I will take them
and we can reinvigorate this series to
the glorious days isn't that right
what's your name that was a dumb name
and smash like if you want more and I
see you guys tomorrow
hey though hey doll